you're bored I'm bored because it looks
like the only way out of this Korona
hell especially in the absence of a
vaccine is going to be digital or what
you might call surveillance plugging
ourselves into technology that knows
your medical history tracks every move
you make and everyone you meet and then
tracks their district classic dystopian
nightmare but we have had a pandemic so
why not it's worked in other countries
doing in corners in quarantine where
digital wristbands taiwan has made a
digital fence using the phone system so
what you can get sort of it's like an
electric dog collar except the only
shock you get is a visit from the
authorities if you turn off your phone
Israel's got a shield in the shape of a
phone app that tells you if you've
crossed paths with an infected person
the Brits are developing one too
although don't hold your breath and
South Korea has gone for the trifecta
cross referencing information from
credit cards CCTV and mobile phones
meaning that infected people and more
importantly who they contacted can be
traced and hey you know what no one's
complaining because it works the results
speak for themselves
so far it's South Korea coming out of
this pandemic with an A+ so please spare
me the George Orwell quotes
we've already surrendered all our data
to where we think are watching this
Facebook Instagram so if you want to
ever leave the house again time to share
with the government updates
Facebook's about to let their users
self-report their coronavirus symptoms
CEO Mark Zuckerberg says having that day
we'll be like a new superpower see
there's nothing we can do anyway